ancient human civilization was far older
and far more advanced than we were ever
taught in school in fact we were so
advanced that whoever built the Great
Pyramid of Giza somehow knew precisely
just how big planet Earth was to such a
precise degree of accuracy that we were
not able to achieve until 1972 following
satellite measurements and mapping and
if you don't believe me I have the data
to prove it and I'll share it with you
in just a moment now if you've seen my
other videos an ancient human
civilization or the pyramids I've
discussed interesting facts such as that
the Great Pyramid of Giza just so
happens to be located at the exact
geographical center of all land mass of
planet Earth
but I mean do you think that's that's a
coincidence I mean what are the odds of
that that the biggest and most
mysterious structure in the history of
mankind just so happens to be located in
the one spot on planet Earth that is
unique and of itself I also discussed
the fact that the Great Pyramid of Giza
has eight sides
not four most people are not aware of
this it's very subtle and it's only
apparent at dusk and dawn on the spring
and autumn equinoxes I also discussed
the fact that the pyramids black soot
residue from candles and torches I mean
how were they able to illuminate these
structures while they were being built
or afterwards I even used the example of
the Sistine Chapel which was built
thousands of years after the pyramids of
Egypt yet years and years of restoration
was required to remove centuries of soot
residue from candles and torches so why
on earth did the Sistine Chapel require
candlelight yet the pyramids didn't I
mean I even used the example and take
the picture on the right of it's in
Egypt that some people say depicts a
light bulb or some sort of technical
device involving electricity I mean you
can see the snake and it connects to the
lotus flower which also connects
seemingly to a cord that goes to a box I
mean what is this I also discussed the
incredible shaft and tunnel system
located throughout the Giza Plateau
there are dozens of shafts that plummet
over a hundred feet down and they're dug
into solid limestone bedrock and these
photos don't even include the horizontal
shafts and tunnels that go into the Giza
Plateau which is a great mystery I mean
what would these used for now in my
videos one of the things I like to
discuss is the
fact that ancient humans seemingly had
some sort of advanced technology to be
able to cut the stone and lift them
however many people disagree with this
and they cite awesome examples on how
primitive methods can absolutely be
utilized to cut and lift stones for
example you have string saws as well as
bronze saws that can be utilized with
sand and water to cut through granite
basalt and even quartzite so no you do
not need advanced machinery or any type
of cutting systems to cut through these
hard stones but there's a massive issue
with this theory which is the fact that
it takes so unbelievably long to cut
through even just one stone in fact it's
pretty interesting that most of the
demonstrations that you can find videos
of don't even show the completion of
these stones they cut a few inches into
it and give up just to prove to you that
yes it's possible to cut through these
stones but explain to me how string saws
or bronze saws can cut the unbelievably
unique curvatures of many of these
stones found throughout Egypt or how
these methods could possibly cut
90-degree angles where in modern times
stone masons need diamond bit drills in
routers to do any of these angles that
you're seeing here I mean even take for
example the 100 ton stone boxes found at
the Sierra p.m. in Egypt these boxes are
more than ten feet tall
15 feet long and weight combined total
of 100 tons of piece 30 tons for the
solid lid and 70 tons for the box but
what makes it even more interesting is
that they're machine cuts somehow to a
level of accuracy to within to 10
thousandths of an inch I mean how could
string saws or bronze saws that utilize
sand cut something so massive I mean
that's one thing these boxes are
humongous or the fact that they're so
unbelievably level I mean can you
demonstrate a string saw doing something
to this level of accuracy to 10
thousandths of an inch but that brings
me to another question involving the
logistics I mean how can these primitive
methods been utilized to do tens of
millions of stone blocks found
throughout pyramids structures and
statues throughout ancient Egypt I mean
there are at least eighty eight zero
pyramids known to exist within Egypt
alone most people aren't aware of that
there of course are familiar with the
three largest and most popular which are
the Pyramids of Giza
there are others being found all the
time even in March of this year they
found an entirely new pyramid buried in
ruins underneath the sands of Egypt or
even the Abu Roash pyramid which appears
to be exploded in charred and is just
completely mysterious and what the heck
happened to that pyramid but I mean what
on earth happened to any pyramid for
them to be in ruins why are we finding
destroyed pyramids underneath the sands
of Egypt what on earth would it take to
destroy a pyramid but when you take into
account that the Great Pyramid of Giza
in itself has 2.3 million stone blocks
should we be finding thousands of
discarded worn-out bronze saws
throughout Egypt yet we've only found
what a few several if that so these
primitive methods don't stack up yes
it's possible to cut through these
stones with these primitive methods but
it doesn't compute if we're being told
that ancient human civilization and the
first pyramids were built approximately
4,200 years ago if every single person
alive at that time was working on this
they would still be working to complete
all of these tens of millions of stone
blocks found throughout Egypt and
they're still finding new ones all the
time now let me touch on the issue of
lifting these stones now I have seen
other primitive methods which are
incredible by the way take for example
Wally from Michigan you can see this
video where he lifts a 20-ton stone
block all by himself it's incredible but
explain to me and let me cite the
example of the massive 1000 ton stones
of Baalbek and Lebanon located near the
temple of Jupiter
I mean how on earth do they move a 1000
ton stone block over a half mile uphill
how on earth did they do that and not to
mention the three blocks that they
lifted up over 30 feet up in place on
top of other stones I mean yeah sure
people can lift individual stones but
how do you drag a thousand ton stone
uphill I mean that really raises some
serious questions but I mean go back to
Egypt and use the example of the
Assyrian I mean you have 60 to 70 tonnes
stone blocks apiece that are more than
ten feet tall I mean these pictures do
not do it justice because if you had a
person standing next to him you'd see
just how massive these stone blocks are
how in the world did Lee lift these
stone blocks on top of these other ones
not to mention how did they cut and
carve these stone blocks do you really
think that something so big
done with a bronze saw or string saws I
mean honestly it doesn't how long would
it take to do just one stone block
never mind lifting it but then they keep
going just the incredible knowledge the
mathematical formulas and equations that
are necessary to build a pyramid is
unbelievable
I mean pyramids on themselves are kind
of like a puzzle and that they have
tunnel systems air shafts and chambers
within them so it's one big massive
puzzle now let me get back to my
original point from the opening in this
video which is that whoever built these
pyramids and design them somehow knew
precisely the exact measurements of
planet Earth and the Great Pyramid of
Giza
is an exact replica based on ratio to
the northern hemisphere down to a ratio
of 43,200 now keep that number 4 3 2 in
mind as we get going now I'm citing the
works of Randall Carlson from his video
series that you can find on youtube
which is cosmic patterns and cycles of
catastrophe you have to check this out
I'm only going to touch on it briefly
and I'm about to leave out so many more
important aspects and information that
will completely sell you on what I'm
trying to explain here but he takes
measurements done through several
sources of the pyramid alone and even
takes into account that the fact that
the Great Pyramid of Giza had 144,000
casing stones on it before it was
destroyed somehow were taken apart but
then he takes measurements of the planet
Earth dating back from the 1830s till
today and somehow these measurements of
planet Earth
take for example 1972 with satellite
mapping and measurements conducted all
equate to a ratio of 43,200 to 1 let me
give you a little bit more information
so you can see how this all fits
together so you have the Sun which has a
diameter of 864,000 or a radius of 430
mm and then you have the moon which is a
diameter of 2160 or the radius being
1080 but if you were to divide the
average distance of the Sun from the
earth about 93 million miles by the
diameter of the Sun 864,000 it would
equal 108 just as if you were to take
the average distance of the moon to the
earth which is you know approximately
233,000 divide that by its diameter you
also equal 108 now take that number 108
which is seen
throughout ancient human civilization I
mean just one example would be the 108
towers found in Cambodia and you'll also
find the number 108 found throughout the
Hindu religion and other sources as well
now I mentioned that the Pyramid of Giza
had 144,000 casing stones
well 144,000 minutes exist in one day
86,400 seconds exists in a day and in a
half day you have 43,200 seconds in a
day now take those numbers 144 or the
864 which is just one decimal short of
being the diameter of the Sun but this
look at the 43,200 seconds and a half
day throughout ancient human
civilization there's a huge focus on as
above so below
well if you take the octahedron which is
essentially two pyramids stacked on top
of each other with the pony ends going
opposite direction the angles combined
equal 1440 think about that there's
fourteen hundred and forty minutes in a
day see if you take the octahedron you
have 1440 degrees of angle now the one
of the things that I mentioned earlier
is the fact that the Great Pyramid of
Giza in this ratio of 43,200 that I'm
referring to even takes into account the
fact that the earth is wider around the
equator than it is around the poles and
when you have the Great Pyramid of Giza
essentially equating to a ratio of
43,200 well again 43,200 is how many
seconds there are in a half day so half
the earth and it just so happens that
the exact measurements create a perfect
ratio of 43,200 is this really just a
coincidence I mean the number 432 is
found through numerous other sources of
ancient human civilization whether be in
Hindu texts whether it be the are Gavita
or the even the pre diluvian Sumerian
king God's equal a total years of 432
thousand or even the Kali Yuga 432,000
or the MA Hugo's which he goes four
billion three hundred and twenty
thousand there's the number four three
two which by the way is incredibly close
to the estimated age of the earth being
approximately four and a half billion
years and look at the number four three
two used in modern times I mean if you
look in the back of the one dollar bill
which for some reason of course has this
pyramid
what has 13 levels of pyramid blocks tax
on it well if you times that by 33 point
3 which
favorite number of Mason's that just so
happens to equal four three two we also
find the number four three two in
harmonic frequencies dating back all the
way to the Sumerians anyways guys I had
to close this up because it's getting
long but take into account everything
that I've covered here whether it be the
location of the pyramid or the fact this
number 432 just ties into everything
from our clock to various sources
throughout ancient human civilization
you have to start asking some real
serious questions here I for one
absolutely do not believe that this is
within the realm of a coincidence in
fact it's evidence that there was a
advanced ancient human civilization that
dates back before the last Cataclysm
which of course I have several videos on
already anyways guys I'm Jimmy this is
bright insight like and subscribe and
leave me a comment let me know what your
thoughts are and I have many videos to
come an all wide variety of topics take
care everybody